in this video we'll study about the
spinothalamic pathways the spinothalamic
pathway is a group of nerve fibers that
runs in the anterior and lateral part of
the spinal cord and carries the
information like pain temperature
pressure and crew touch to the brain
this is the cross section of the spinal
cord showing the position of the
spinothalamic pathway it is made up of
two distinct nerve fiber tracts anterior
spinothalamic tract and the lateral
spinothalamic tract the anterior spinal
thermic tract carries the sensation of
crude dodging pressure whereas a lateral
spinothalamic tract carries the
sensation of pain and temperature before
progressing further it is important to
understand the concept of lamina of
spinal cord also known as the rx-8
laminate this is a section of central
butterfly-shaped gray matter of the
spinal cord which is divided into ten
lamina named one to ten from posterior
to anterior for the spinothalamic tract
we are mainly concerned with the first
for laminar lamina to is known as the
substantial gelatin OSA and lamina three
and four collectively are known as the
nucleus pro prius now this is a dorsal
nerve root of the spinal cord and the
neurons presented are the pseudo
unipolar neurons these are the
first-order neurons of the spinothalamic
tract the peripheral process of these
neurons carries the information from all
these receptors and the central process
of these neurons relays this information
into this panel cord now the central
process which brings information from
pain and temperature receptors forms a
lateral spinothalamic tract and these
nerve fibers first relay in the second
lamina of the spinal cord whereas the
nerve fibers which break information
from the crew touch and pressure form
the anterior spinal thalmic tract and
these relay into the third and fourth
lamina of the spinal cord in these
lamina these neurons form synapses with
the second order neurons which
immediately cross to the opposite side
of the spinal cord and travel up to the
thalamus on the opposite side of this
Kord so now we know how the first-order
neurons of the spinothalamic tract relay
into the spinal cord and form synapses
with the second-order neurons let's
further understand how these spinal
thermic tract is organized up till the
brain here you see multiple
cross-sections of spinal cord from
lumbar spinal cord up till mid brain and
a section of cerebrum and thalamus the
spinothalamic tract begins when the
nerve fibers from the upper and lower
part of the body enter the spinal cord
at respective levels the nerve fibers
from the lower part of the body enter at
the lumbar spinal cord form synapses in
the exit lamina of the spinal cord from
here second order neurons arise which
cross to the opposite side and form the
drug which travels up to the thalamus on
the opposite side of spinal cord in a
similar way the nerve fibers from the
upper part of the body enter a dist
cervical spinal cord cross to the
opposite side and travel to the thalamus
in the thalamus the second order neurons
form synapses with the third order
neurons these neurons project to the
primary sensory cortex of the brain this
area is also known as the post central
gyrus where all these sensations are
perceived so this is a brief overview
about the spinothalamic pathway thank
you so much for watching this video like
our channel on YouTube for all the
upcoming videos and make sure to LIKE
our channel on Facebook for flashcards
and upcoming notifications